i had
five messages for the leaders today
the first one is on data sharing
we have to share comprehensive and
accurate
data in real time with the ecdc platform
we are making 220 million euros
available
to finance a safe cross-border transfer
of patients
where it is needed and for that the good
use of the money requires good
information in exchange
the second topic was also a topic on
sharing
but in this time in this case experience
and
analysis the third topic is testing
our goal is keeping the virus in check
and that goes through massive testing
the fourth topic is tracing
so testing and tracing go hand in hand
22 member states have developed
a tracing app or are developing a
tracing app
at the moment being we have
approximately 50 million
downloads concerning smart phone holders
but this is not enough therefore i asked
leaders in each country to encourage
a massive uptake by citizens so a
massive
download of the app by smartphone
holders
and finally the fifth point indeed is
vaccines and vaccination
we have three priorities here
the first is ensuring validation
of vaccines speedily and we do
have to do the validation at a good pace
while providing all the safety
guarantees
the second priority is to ensure indeed
the fair distribution of vaccines
to member states but thirdly before that
before
we really go into the vaccination indeed
the infrastructure for vaccination must
be ready
now is the time for patients for
determination and for discipline from
all of us
and that way altogether we will overcome
the virus
thank you